[Music]
over 30 million people have contracted
covered and recovered
then are believed to have natural
immunity
that typically offers better protection
than a vaccine
but the price is higher with so many
unknown long-term effects
vaccines may not be quite as effective
but they're also not as dangerous
i had really no side effects only the
normal one but
everybody should know from like the
influence erection
and that i get i was very tired for one
evening
some compare it to a hangover human
trials of several vaccines now show
positive results but that doesn't mean
life will go back to normal just yet
here in an old people's home in italy
the vulnerable can once again
get close to their loved ones but in a
different way
we're making progress the serum
institute of india the world's largest
vaccine producer says it's made 40
million doses of astrazeneca's potential
corona vaccine
it's enrolled 1600 participants for late
stage trials
and sooner we'll be making novo vac's
rival shot as both seek regulatory
approval
india's vaccine bid is big
service has always been important to
navnith huda
from donating blood since a young age to
holding tree plantation drives
he was disappointed when he couldn't
join the indian army to serve the
country
but then another opportunity in his
north indian hometown of rothath came
along
he volunteered for the clinical trials
of corvaxin
a covert vaccine being developed in
india
people told me it was risky but for me
it was an opportunity to be of service
i'm happy to dedicate my body to my
country my fellow countrymen
whenever i'm needed i'll be there
it was this enthusiasm to volunteer for
the covet vaccine trials that stood out
for dr savita varma
in previous clinical trials dr varma has
led it took
much more convincing to find volunteers
for this one she had hundreds calling in
within days
so many people came forward because they
wanted to do a greater good
and like for phase one only within three
four days we had
250 volunteers registered with us and it
isn't just
individuals in india who are trying to
play their part to help deal with this
pandemic
1400 kilometers away the western city of
pune
is home to the world's largest vaccine
producer
the sarah institute of india produces
over 1.5 billion vaccine doses every
year
for use in 170 countries now it is
poised to play a crucial role in the
global bid for the coronavirus vaccine
already this facility is producing 30
million doses of the oxford vaccine
every month
it is set to stockpile 300 million doses
by the end of the year
we rejigged our capacities we sacrificed
a lot of products that we were going to
launch
in europe us and that's why we were able
to have that much spare capacity
available for making these four or five
different covet vaccines
and all at a low cost of a few hundred
rupees
roughly four to five euros
with the help of the gates foundation
the institute is investing to provide
vaccines to over 90 low and
middle-income countries at an affordable
cost
for other vaccines at different stages
of trials
are also being produced here none of
these have been approved yet
but the company's ceo adar punawala
is confident that starting production
early with the support of the indian
government
is the right move for 48 hours
if and when the vaccine is licensed we
have a lot of product that we can
distribute of course
it's a risk if the product for whatever
reason fails at the last minute which
now
let me say looks very unlikely now
things are looking
far better at least for the oxford
astrazeneca vaccine
unavala expects emergency approvals for
the oxford vaccine to come through early
next year
back in rohtak navaneet will still be
going in for follow-up tests next year
that check how well he is doing with the
vaccine
and he will not be alone while his
father was
at first worried for the safety of his
son
he has now been swayed by navni's
enthusiasm
the swede huda is now a vaccine trial
volunteer as well
and proud to stand shoulder to shoulder
with his son
in what he sees as a service to the
country
and to the world while scientists
continue to work on a coronavirus
vaccine let's talk to
life alexander about vaccines versus
natural immunity so what's better
getting infected recovering and becoming
immune
or an actual vaccine when it comes to
covert
well um at this point um it's hard to
tell
because we don't actually understand
exactly how long lasting how long lived
natural immunity is after a
um a saskov2 infection
so far the data indicate that antibody
responses are
quite durable at least over the course
of five to six months
but we don't know how long they will
last what we do now is that from
endemic coronaviruses so other
coronaviruses that cause the common cold
that
the immunity is not that long lived that
you can get reinfected
after one or two years and the hope is
that with the vaccine-induced immunity
that they
will be able to produce a more
long-lived and more robust immunity than
natural infection does
because for for some other diseases the
vaccine actually does
induce a better immune response than the
natural
infection and then vice versa with
others like measles
exactly so there are examples for both
there are
some examples where a natural infection
induces a much more robust and
long-lived immunity than
vaccines have been able to do and in
other examples
the vaccines are better than the natural
infection
and that often has to do with the
pathogen or the virus that causes the
infection
if that virus has the capability to
escape the immune system
as in the case of hiv or certain herpes
viruses
the viruses are able to hide from the
immune system
and the hope is that you can create a
vaccine that
is able to bypass this property of the
of the virus to hide and this way induce
a more robust and more long-lived
immunity
um there's also a there are many
unknowns as far as the long-term effects
of
of covert go i mean for young and old
blood clots heart damage
chronic fatigue memory loss fertility
issues
seizures temporary paralysis increased
risk of parkinson's
alzheimer's are there any other any
others that you'd like to add to the
list
no definitely there will be long-term
consequences
of covet 19. at this point it is
still too early to tell how frequent
they will be and how long
lived these these consequences
and long-term effects will be what we do
see is that there's quite
a substantial uh proportion of people
that suffer from fatigue and chronic
fatigue syndrome that is a
very severe condition that basically
leaves patients unable to work unable to
go
about their normal lives for several
months then there is
other effects such as alterations
of the respiratory system you see people
that are severely compromised
for several months after the infection
and of course we have these neurological
effects that you mentioned so in
addition to the quite high mortality
and and the strain on the healthcare
system we have to take into account
those long-term effects
and it makes it um more important even
to have as an effective vaccine at hand
what do you expect an effective vaccine
against covert to be able to do
so the studies that are currently being
carried out and also the first study
where interim results have been reported
have been designed and powered
to show a reduction in saskov2 infection
symptomatic infection what i would hope
which is a secondary endpoint of many of
the studies
what i would hope and i also think that
these vaccines will
be able to do is to reduce the frequency
of severe covet
which means reduce the frequency of
of lung failure where people have to be
intubated
and and treated on the icu and also to
reduce mortality
from berlin's charity hospital life
alexander thank you very much
finally your questions here's our
science correspondent derek williams
biontech and pfizer have developed a
vaccine to prevent covid19
are there pharmaceutical companies also
working on therapies to cure patients
who
already have it as we all celebrate
very promising interim vaccine candidate
results and and look forward to possible
breakthroughs with others
soon it's kind of easy to ignore the
elephant in the room which is that
covet 19 is going to make this winter in
the northern hemisphere
long hard and likely very grim
even in a perfect world with a vaccine
approved
by the end of november it'll take many
more months
if not years to distribute it and
although doctors
have gotten better at treating patients
thereby improving survival rates we
still don't have
really effective drugs to treat those
who become ill
or who become very ill in fact a major
disputed pre-print study released by the
who last month
more or less said that most of what's in
our medicine cabinet now
that can be produced at a large scale
basically
doesn't really work so why don't we have
more compounds to help people who have
the disease and are in dire straits
well for a couple of reasons in some
ways
developing tailored treatments is a
trickier process
than developing a vaccine because
vaccines all do the same thing
they stimulate the immune system to
fight off an invader so
we can judge end points pretty clearly
um
can it do that safely and can it do it
effectively
but treatments usually have incremental
effects
and can affect the disease process in a
lot of different ways
which is why in the search for therapies
we focused on what are called
repurposed drugs treatments that we
already have
that work for other diseases and most
importantly
that have already proven safe to take
because
it all had to go fast right so so yes
thousands of drugs have been screened or
are in repurposing studies and and some
are promising but as
as we approach a year of covet 19 we
still
don't have therapies that can knock it
out effectively